I have a flight to catch in a few hours.
So, this is going to be a much speedier
version of my normal videos. But 04 Mini
has been released along with 03 from
OpenAI and it's generating insane hype
like this. But is the hype justified?
Call me cynical, but they do lean
towards giving early access to people
that they know are going to massively
hype up their new models. Now, don't get
me wrong, they are much better than
previous models like 01. They're just
not above genius level. I can prove that
in multiple ways, but I'm just going to
give you a selection. And yes, I have
read most of the system card and tested
the model 20 times already. I should say
both models because it's 04 mini and 03.
For those completely new to AI, by the
way, these are now the best models
within chatbt, which is different, of
course, from Google's Gemini 2.5 Pro or
Anthropics Claude 3.7. Others like Tyler
Cohen says that 03 is AGI, and honestly,
I hear people talk about Tyler Cohen. I
have no idea who he is, but I don't
believe 03 is AGI. For me, AGI is when a
model can perform better than the human
average at most tasks that a human can
do. For knowledge, coding, and
mathematics, that is absolutely true, as
long as you don't focus on experts, but
in general, it's not so much the case.
There are many examples I could have
chosen, but check this one out. Here are
five lines, and I asked how many
overlaps do they have in total. It said
there are eight distinct points where
the five drawn line segments intersect.
Now I know you guys and you might pause
and say well if you extrapolate the
lines maybe they intersect eight times.
Ah it's not wrong. Nah this is exactly
what 03 meant. Here for example is one
point of intersection. Anyway I can't
explain my entire theory about AGI here.
This is a very brief video but it is
definitely not hallucination free. That
is complete BS and OpenAI know it. It's
a great model a big improvement. I think
04 Mini is possibly comparable to Gemini
2.5 Pro on a good day, but it's
definitely not hallucination free. Both
models are trained from the ground up to
use tools, and I think that's an epic
way to improve models, and they will get
even more useful very fast. In case you
think I am dehyping 03 too much, it was
the first model to get 6 out of 10 on
the first 10 public questions of my own
benchmark, Simple Bench. I was genuinely
impressed with some of its answers. And
even though I disagree that it would
take a fairly old man 3 to 5 minutes to
climb up to the top of a skyscraper, it
nevertheless got the question right for
the first time of any OpenAI model. But
back to the theme you heard earlier, it
can sometimes make some pretty basic
mistakes like saying that a glove that
falls out of the trunk or boot of a car
which is going over a bridge seems
likely to fall into the river because
the trunk area is open and the river is
directly below. Well, what happened to
the bridge? As I hinted at in my
previous video released just wait 3 4
hours ago. It does sometimes get this
question right cuz I kind of indirectly
got early access to 03. But more often
than not, it gets it wrong. I don't know
about you, but if I met someone who was
above genius level, I would expect them
to at least consider that the glove
might fall out of the car onto the
bridge itself. O4 Mini High gets four
out of 10 on the public set of
questions, which is actually really not
bad for a small quick model. Both
models, by the way, are coming to the
plus tier, which is really making me
start to wonder about paying for the
Protier. But anyway, here are the
prices. These numbers probably don't
mean much to you, but the key point of
comparison is with 03 and Gemini 2.5
Pro. Very roughly speaking, Gemini 2.5
Pro is about 3 to four times cheaper
than 03. So bear that in mind when you
see the benchmark results in a second.
The first benchmark result is on the
overlap test and yes, Gemini gets it
right. Oh, and by the way, speaking of
multimodality, Gemini 2.5 Pro can handle
YouTube videos and just raw videos and
03 can't. I initially got really excited
when I saw that you could upload videos
to 03, but it's just doing an analysis
of the metadata. Now, I know 03 is
trained to use tools natively, and I was
particularly impressed with the way that
it analyzed my benchmark website,
created an image, a cover image for it,
and did a deep dive analysis, which was
pretty much accurate. It gave
speculation about why the front runners
were better, and honestly, some pretty
nuanced advice about the benchmark
itself and its limitations. Now, some of
you may say, what about the 03 WOW video
that I made earlier? And first of all,
AI moves very quickly. So even 4 or 5
months can change a lot in AI. It's
still a wow model, just not as wow in
comparison with say Gemini 2.5 or even
sometimes Claude 3.7 thinking. There is
another key detail though that they
slipped into the presentation. They said
that 03, the one I covered back in
December, was quote benchmark optimized.
the ones we're getting as the Ark Prize
confirmed are smaller in terms of
compute or less thinking time than the
version that they tested. Now, I am
presuming that what they meant by
benchmark optimized was that they let 03
think for a lot longer, have a lot more
inference time compute. In other words,
we are not quite getting the model that
crushed ARC AGI. Some other quick
details before we get to the benchmarks
and both models have a 200,000 token
context window. I think roughly 150,000
words, but they can output up to 80,000
words, which I think is pretty cool.
Their knowledge cutoff, which you can
think of as the limits of their training
data, is June 1st, 2024. That compares
to January 2025 for Gemini 2.5 Pro. It
seems, and I haven't had time to check
this, that they are still basing it on
GPT40, hence the lack of an updated
training cutoff date. Time for some
benchmarks. And don't hate on me for
literally just getting a screen grab
from the YouTube video. For competitive
mathematics, 03 and 04 Mini do extremely
well on a data set that couldn't have
been in their training data. For
reference on this benchmark, Gemini 2.5
Pro gets around 86%. Now, with multiple
attempts, Grock 3 gets 93%. But we don't
quite know how many attempts this was
for OpenAI. I would presume just first
attempt. Either way, as the narrators
said, when you allow these models to
have tools, they are extremely good to
the point of saturating some of these
competitive math benchmarks. Likewise,
for competitive code, if you can
benchmark it, they can crush it. These
models, indeed, even other model
families are essentially eval
maximizers. As I touched on in my video
from what 4 hours ago, for PhD level
science, you can see the results here,
83.3 and 81.4. For reference, Gemini
gets 84% and Claude 3.7 Sonnet gets
84.8%. That's with multiple attempts for
Claude, but just a single attempt for
Gemini 2.5. So, Gemini 2.5 is better on
a single attempt than either model. Kind
of seems a little bit strange to be
declaring AGI tonight, but not when
Gemini 2.5 Pro came out. For me, neither
are AGI, but I am not an AGI deniialist.
I think it is coming in the next few
years. Simplest version of my definition
is when I would hire 04, for example,
over a smart human being. Could they
edit an entire video without random
glitches or cutting off key images? For
that matter, could they do my Amazon
shopping without putting me 10 grand in
debt? I do get it at coming up with
quick drafts that seem incredibly
intelligent and often are. They are
incredible, far smarter than me in that
sense. I couldn't get any of these
scores in any of these exams, but it is
fairly inadvisable to make comparisons
to human IQ because how many super crazy
coders or PhDs do you know that could
score like this but not count the number
of overlaps? Or think of there being a
bridge beneath the glove that's falling.
If it's in their training data, amazing.
if it's not on the mmu which is a bit
like the mmlu in the sense of it spans
many different domains but it focuses on
questions involving charts and tables
and graphs and things like that 03 gets
82.9%. That is genuinely better than
Gemini 2.5 pros 81.7%. So well done to
open AAI on that. Now on humanity's last
exam, which you can think of as a
benchmark for really obscure knowledge,
it was almost slightly disappointing for
me even though the previous record was
OpenAI itself with Deep Research. Now in
fairness again 03 beats Gemini 2.5 Pro
which got 18% in this benchmark. But
given that deep research was powered by
an early version openai said of 03 I was
expecting a little bit more especially
with the quote new and improved someone
said 03 with Python and browsing tools
or even 04 for that matter. I thought
they might have injected more knowledge
into it. That is kind of harsh because
they're just challenging their own
record in this benchmark. So well done
to them again. The release notes from
OpenAI were fairly interesting with
evaluations by quote external experts
having 03 making 20% fewer major errors.
That's great, but what happened to it
being quote hallucination free? If I saw
Sam Orman retweet that a new model was
quote hallucination free and I was an
average white collar worker, I would be
panicking. What's the real truth? It is
absolutely not hallucination free and
making fewer mage errors is great, but
still conceds that it does make major
errors. As we've seen already on one
part of ADA's polyglot coding benchmark,
we can see that 03 on high settings
indeed sets a record. It's more than 10
points higher than Gemini 2.5 Pro. But
you may remember that 01 on high
settings, as in thinking for a long
time, using lots of chains of Thor, cost
almost $200. That compares to $6 for
Gemini. 03 high, in other words, may eek
out Gemini 2.5 Pro and therefore become
widely used, but at an extreme cost. or
the TLDDR of all of that is even in
those domains where 03 has taken the
lead, it hasn't taken the cost effective
lead on Codeex CLI, their agent that you
can run from your terminal, they're
clearly taking aim at Claude Code, but
obviously given that it's only been
around 2 and 1/2 hours, I haven't had
time to test it. Of course, that may be
turbocharged if OpenAI by Windsurf, the
competitor to Cursor itself. Of course,
if you check out my previous video,
Kevin While, the chief product officer
of OpenAI, said very clearly that
competitive coding is not always the
same as front-end coding, for example.
So, you'll have to test it yourself. As
always, it comes down to how much
highquality data there is in your domain
and indeed a diversity of data. As we
all know in machine learning, sometimes
you can overtrain on bits of data, as
you can see in this example. Yes, this
was 03 by the way. I bet some of the
first comments will be, "What about
testing both models on SimpleBench given
that the API is out tonight?" Well,
given my flight, that will have to be my
colleague who is hopefully going to do
it tonight. And so, the results should
be on the website tonight. Fingers
crossed. I suspect it may just take the
lead from Gemini 2.5 Pro, albeit costing
a lot more. But, as pretty much all of
you know by now, we couldn't test 03 on
Simple Bench without Weights and Biases,
who are the sponsors of today's video.
If you want to check out their weave
platform, you can do so via the
SimpleBench website or of course with
the link in the description. We should
be doing some Discord workshops on my
Patreon to get you started on Weave, but
essentially it's what we use to
benchmark these models. It's kind of
like being in one of those Mercedes
where you can see like a thousand
options for tweaking things, improving
things, and comparing things. And as I
mentioned before, they have an AI
academy with free courses. Thanks as
ever to Weights and Biases for keeping
Simplebench going. Now, the system card,
which because of the flight, for one of
the first times in video history on AI
explained, I've only read part of.
Nevertheless, here are some highlights
with meter finding examples of reward
hacking, maxing their score. In other
words, not by the model itself, solving
the challenge, but tweaking the
parameters so it seems like it solved
the challenge. A bit like hacking a game
to change your score to win the game.
And 03 did this roughly 1% of the time.
Also, do you remember that paper
recently from meter that I've been
discussing with their authors where the
length of a task that a model can do is
doubling every 7 months? Well, there are
many caveats to that paper, but Meta do
say that when they analyzed 03, they
said they found capabilities exceeding
those of other public models and
surpassing their projections from
previous capability scaling trends that
we saw. In other words, the time horizon
of software tasks that they complete
with greater than 50% reliability may be
doubling in less than 7 months.
Obviously, I'll have to come back to
some of this stuff in other videos, but
here's another highlight that 03 and 04
Mini are on the cusp of being able to
meaningfully help noviceses create known
biological threats that would cross
OpenAI's own high-risk threshold, which
would mean that they couldn't even
release the model. I keep telling people
this that because of responsible scaling
policies from Anthropic and OpenAI, they
are promising people that they soon
won't even be able to release certain
models. That will be reassuring or
disappointing to you depending on your
perspective. Back to dehyping though,
cuz I'm sure tonight you're going to see
plenty of 03 is AGI screaming face
thumbnails. Just to drown out that
noise, check out OpenAI research
engineer interview performance. Look at
that incredible exponential you can see
from 01 up to 04. Well, kind of not
really. Also, paperbench, which is
testing whether AIs can replicate AI
research papers. I bet this particular
chart doesn't find itself in many AGI is
here crazy thumbnails that you see or
videos for that matter that you see
tonight. Look at 01's performance 24%
and 03 without browsing 18%. O4 Mini
25%. I do get it. It's not a perfect
apples to apples, but this is not
exactly an exponential obligatory
caveat. I am expecting progress over the
course of this year. I'm just saying not
every chart backs up the AGI hype. I'll
leave you with these two more optimistic
thoughts on 03. While it may be
demanding more and more compute,
performance does continue to rise and
rise. And that's not even to mention
letting the models think for longer,
which is another entire axis we can
exploit. As Nome Brown of OpenAI said,
there is still a lot of room to scale
both of these further. So, if you ignore
the headlines and drown out the hype,
which is to be honest good advice for
all times in life, 03 represents genuine
progress. Well done to OpenAI. If you
want to check out more ways that AI is
improving, check out my video from
around 4 hours ago. And either way, have
a wonderful